[Music]
to me it's about community and yet we're
a community garden and the vegetables
are great but the most important thing
is about the communities right out of
the chain Wow
we involved in the garden disabled
program with the children they come over
they learn how to garden and then from
digging up or picking the produce we
take it them into the kitchen to show
them how to cook with it I pick rakes up
from his house and then we decide what
we're going to do for that day or night
I'm just giving you one ring good fun
eat have a good laugh good game appalled
we reckon about that one
what is it something back to the
community they've been good to me among
over two girls so
just opportunity to repay
nice to do something for somebody else
that a volunteer type situation not been
paid for
[Music]
and I thought up a little spare time and
what I like to do this so women playing
half court we need to find our line they
are found that we have a huge amount of
community volunteers that we are heavily
reliant on going if it wasn't for the
volunteers we wouldn't be able to
provide the support that we do at run
your high school we're really really
thankful for the amount of volunteers
that give up their time
[Music]